[Musique]
spécial élections municipales bienvenue
dans ce nouveau débat des élections
municipales et communautaires sur
martinique la première radio et internet
débat consacré cette fois à la ville de
saint-esprit avec cinq listes en lice à
cette date du 17 février dans notre
studio les cinq candidats têtes de liste
sont là et avec carlin livory qui anime
avec moi un bon soir alain nous allons
vous les présenter tout de suite
tout commençait alors nous commençons
par par ordre alphabétique donc olivier
bérisson 46 ans cadre à la banque
postale liste mme fauste esprits vous
êtes le fondateur libération du
mouvement politique et spirituelle mon
bonjour autre candidat tête de liste
michel duval âgé de 63 ans travailleur
social
il est à la tête de la liste
saint-esprit double août il investit par
le mime
il avait déjà été candidat en 2014 on
sent même si l'écran bon soir la
martinique
ensuite la rize plantain 63 ans
technicienne à la poste
votre liste cohésion spirit jens où vous
êtes soutenus par pays afs est
conseillère territoriale de la majorité
vous êtes la seule femme candidate alors
bonsoir a tous un sous le plateau et ses
aiguilles herman hospital a expliqué
qu'ils nous écoutent je pense nombreux
ce soir quatrième candidat dans cet
ordre alphabétique bien car daniel
sainte-rose 64 ans agriculteur et ancien
postier vous êtes de la liste alliance
des forces spiritaines membre du groupe
politique dirigée par l'ancien maire de
saint-esprit justement eric ayotte
vous êtes également un ancien militant
des forces martiniquaises de progrès
c'est ce qu'on nous a donné comme fish
vous avez des choses à corriger là
dessus oui bon pari que tu as je suis
retraité mais eric ayotte manque d ça ne
me convient pas je ne je ne suis pas le
candidat des week-ends on sait pas ce
qu'on a dit on a dit que vous êtes
membre du groupe politique qui était
dirigé à l'époque par l'ancien maire
éric ayotte
avez-vous fait partie de l'équipe d'éric
ayotte plus ou moins
j'ai fait partie d'une association qui
s'appelait lui dise et pas forcément
dirigé par righi kayode c'était un
groupe et monsieur eric anet et est
membre comme les autres donc c'est à ce
titre que vous étiez proche de lui quoi
voilà tout à fait ok et pour terminer
donc fait michel tir aux 47 à venir
sortant vous allez conduire la liste le
saint-esprit avant tout d'être le petit
vice président de l'espace sud est aussi
président de la fédération de l'est
républicain de martine et bernard
bonsoir à tous et à toutes
bon soit au spirit et en martinique est
qu'ils nous écoutent voit la bande et
bon débarras avoue 5 donc avant de
câlins nous présente la commune donc de
saint-esprit disons quand même que nous
précisons que cette émission réalisée
donc par claudine et et le bjp elle alla
donc vous nous présenter en quelques
lignes
cette commune de saint-esprit l'une
l'une de ces communes de notre île qui
n'a pas de liaison directe avec la mer
va tout à fait alors saint-esprit
enclavé dans le sud de l'île cet esprit
entouré par cinq communes du causse
rivière saab rivière pilote vauquelin
françois rivière salée la commune citant
sur 2300 48 hectares et les peuples et
au 1er janvier dernier de 9432
spiritains spirit elle une population
légère baisse par rapport à 2012 c'est
la seule commune où la fête patronale ne
tombe pas un jour fixe mais selon la
fête du saint-esprit auxquels sont les
consacrer son église
la commune a longtemps été dirigée par
le parti communiste de 1947 à 1977 avec
genre de fitte duval avant de tomber
dans l'escarcelle de la droite avec
raymond fait du tueur dose et douars tir
haut puis eric ayotte et jusqu'en 2014
et à l'élection de fait une fiche fait
michel terrot il ya six ans donc voilà
le maire sortant qui est donc à cette
table alors saint-esprit où bianca car
eto'o a réalisé ce reportage que vous
allez pouvoir entendre dans quelques
instants auprès d'habitants ou de
passants finalement en général on
demande un plutôt aux personnes qu'on
interroge s'ils sont habitante aux
habitants de saint-esprit
voilà est donc en principe ce sont des
habitants rencontrés au hasard et qui
ont bien voulu
lui livrer à son micro ces quelques
commentaires j'attends que les prochains
candidats soit un petit peu plus à
l'écouté des problématiques des
commerçants que ce ne soit pas que des
promesses
quand il parle de redynamiser le bourg
quand il parle de prendre le pouls du
tissu économique spirit r on ne trouve
pas des investisse comme il faut puisque
on est à l'intérieur des terres et ce
type de communes n'intéresse personne
un mac d'une boîte de nuit il ya des
gens qui sont à pied est maintenant un
pur gens qui sont des plats venus car
vos goûts y'a pas de fouet et payantes
budget bas et 2002 aux communes cet
esprit nouveau connectés fait l'hôpital
tout autour du bourg sur les caniveaux
vous vraiment trop forte et dangereuse
il n'y a pas assez de logements au
saint-esprit tu avais un changement pour
les jeunes de les lui travaillait
trouver du boulot pour les jeunes parce
qu'il y en a un petit peu partout dans
les coups elle a pour nom des
associations qui nous permettent de
faire d'autres trucs on y va on fit rue
du souvenir la jeunesse de la chose tous
travailler des emplois jeunes d'être
comme ça de voir comme de vieux qualité
de mettre tout ça de kamina comme si ces
grillages que des délinquants
stiglitz grandit de jour en jour placer
une caméra parisiens se déplacent de
l'autre côté
j'attends comme ceci ou cela commence un
sentier vous bénisse la fontaine mais là
je vois pourquoi ce tour de la manche et
qui doit tourner à sa place en 3 la wii
guidon la wii chercher samedi dernier
schalke au marché à montant les marches
mais jeunes hommes ont fait la même si
on n'avait pas les marches de maître
même les rend pas et puis au niveau des
crues de vidéos a fait quelque chose de
chaque grosse pluie
la ville est complètement ignoré et ça
fait au moins 25 ans je suis ici ayant
réussi
et puis que l'homme est né voilà donc
pour ces quelques commentaires qui n'ont
évidemment pas valeur de sondage
donc quelques réactions autour de la
table qui souhaitent réagir alors pas
maryse plante et puisque vous avez été
désigné pour répondre à la première
question thématique c'est à dire à
partir des thèmes que nous avons choisi
là il s'agit de commenter de manière
succincte ce que vous avez entendu de la
part donc de ces personnes rencontrées
par bianca quartetto on va peut-être
commencer par vous olivier bérisson
écouter
et action sont exactement celles que
nous entendons lors de nous à nos
visites sur le terrain il y a évidemment
un problème d'animation et de dynamisme
et quand on parle de promesses non
tenues
je crois qu'il faut complètement changé
la donne politique
la première promesse d'être le spirit r
et quand je disputais le martiniquais
l'être humain et donc on ne peut pas
s'amuser à jouer avec la vie des gens
en faisant des chantiers de ces notions
la veille des élections est plus une
fois que l'échangé des siens se sont
terminées il est jeune son livre y
retourne exactement la case départ donc
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut vraiment
prendre en compte que la vie n'est pas
un jus et qu'on ne peut pas utiliser la
vie des gens simplement pour des besoins
électoralistes
monsieur fait michel dire où le micro
trottoir ou trois faits le premier
intervenant est clair il parle de
redynamisation du bourg
elie il dit aussi que les commerçants se
sentir quelque peu délaissé monsieur
livory comme l'a dit votre collègue
monsieur cas où ça ne fait pas office de
son âge
un correctif simplement la ville du
saint-esprit le vous avez parlé de la
population le dernier recensement vient
de se terminer il s'est terminé ya du
joug je vous annonce déjà les chiffres
officiels devant être publié dans
quelques jours mais je peux d'ores et
déjà vous annoncer que nous avons gagné
500 habitants nous frôlons les dix mille
habitants
donc la ville de cet esprit a gagné 500
habitants nous sommes une ville
attractive
en ce qui concerne le dynamisme il faut
vraiment être sourd et aveugle pour ne
pas constater le dynamisme culturel
connaît le cet esprit de la médiathèque
été inaugurée depuis 2014 le bilan va
vers le bilan ma mère mais tous les
jours où il n'y a pas une semaine qui se
passe au cet esprit sent qu'il ya une
activité culturelle et sportive à
l'initiative de la ville
pas plus tard que vendredi est celui le
week-end dernier il y avait une parade
nocturne qui a réuni plusieurs milliers
de martinique au saint-esprit
pas plus tard que la sagesse que trois
jours il ya trois jouent encore il y
avait encore de le marché des cours de
bachata
non on n'a jamais vu autant d'activités
vous votre équipe très de l'animation ce
qui concerne l'insécurité dynamisant
deux mots puisqu'il faut réagir où il
incarnait à vis de la question des
canalisations c'est normal monsieur car
oui je me suis dit voulant mesdames
messieurs nous avons effectivement il
est allé la vidéoprotection et vous
pouvez vérifier les chiffres ils sont
publics
la commune où la délinquance est la plus
basse dans le sud
c'est le cet esprit les chiffres sont là
ils peuvent être vérifiés tucak peut
aller vérifier auprès de la gendarmerie
ou
et de la préfecture il y avait un réel
lozès vous poser des questions quand
même c'était fred michel avait de réels
besoins d'assistance
oui mais moi je peux vous interrompt
pour vous demander s'il y avait quelques
motifs pour installer temps de caméras
vous dites qu'il n'ya pas de délinquance
je finis mais ce qu'il y avait une forte
délinquance qui motivait d'installer des
caméras
voilà une phrase émane de la
vidéoprotection et ça rassure et ça
protège et ça permet d'élucider les
infractions et toutes les communes sont
en train d'installer la vidéoprotection
dans la liste est longue ce n'est pas
sécuritaire un peu la vidéo offerts aux
tractions pas du tout sa vie des otages
et pour protéger grâce à une réforme de
surveillance aussi aimé mais s'il
rassure monsieur la population et ça
permet d'élucider les regrets vous ne
regrettez pas d'avoir installé c'est
certaines devient la population des très
courts est dans une meilleure réaction
merci beaucoup monsieur miguel duale
merci beaucoup
moi j'ai le sentiment profond réaction
de monsieur triaud que ceux qui ont été
interrogés sur le trou 3 on eux
n'habitent pas le saint esprit je crois
que ça prouve encore qu'il ya un manque
d'écouté au niveau des spiritains
l'insécurité elle est là même si des
chiffres ont baissé mais elle est là les
prisons maintenant les caméras
probablement et à les installer
mais ça ne fait que déplacer le problème
c'est à dire moi j'habite en plein boom
même si j'observe une tranquillité à
proximité de leurs j'habite mais
ailleurs d'autres personnes se plaignent
en périphérie du goût à la périphérie du
bon non non moi j'avais au centre bourg
oui j'ai compris mes sauts qui se
plaignent vous devez vous il ya déjà
constater que le centre bourg et des
caméras par conséquent on ne peut pas
investir
de la technologie à mon avis il faut
créer la communication aller vers les
êtres humains ce sont des êtres humains
comme nous mêmes qui savent parler et
voir avec eux mais leur permettre
d'exprimer ce qu'ils nous ressortent à
trouver des solutions avec eux donc on
va passer son temps à vsd la technologie
qui sont plus à but répressif qu à but
préventif
madame longtemps longtemps votre
réaction à ce micro trottoir c'est la
réalité la réalité parce que nous avons
une équipe municipale qui est
inexistante et ça se ressent sur le
terrain
dans ce que ça fait pratiquement le nom
que je bats la campagne à la campagne en
ville et c'est le même constat
il ya un fossé entre les élites et et la
population le maire est un élu de
proximité et si une équipe municipale
ce n'est pas le maire mais c'est
l'équipe municipale donc effectivement
le meilleur pu être empêchés mais a déjà
joué il ya des conseils municipaux et
c'est vrai que nous avons deux des
caniveaux qui n'existe peut-être plus
ailleurs et j'avais de mettre ses
balances et s oui seulement qui a on a
encore ce genre de deux trucs qui date
je ne sais pas de quelle année qua non
mais je crois que c'est vrai que c'est
pas un sondage de micro trottoir mais ça
reflète la situation parce que je peux
vous dire que les commerçants sont en
souffrance et je peux vous le dire
et comme il me disait un exemple c'est
vrai que le maire ne peut pas tout faire
au moins une petite visite petit passage
bonjour comment ça va comme ça se passe
donc il ya l'édilité et la population
donc le micro trottoir n'est pas un
sondage mais c'est la réalité
voilà et puis dernière réaction daniel
sainte rose
allez-y monsieur oui samy kotto traa a
valeur de deux tests la réaction l éclat
significative du constat et du
diagnostic que l'on fait notre présence
ici
cc c'est la juste représentation de ski
ou de ce que du reflet de ceux de ce que
disent ces personnes là en réalité
et quand le maire parle quand on parle
il n'y avait pas que des contraintes et
encore du dal qui disait souhaiter que
le maire continue son action mais il n'y
a jamais d'unanimité mais simplement
quand j'entends le maire en parlant des
caméras dire que c'est à titre préventif
et sécuritaire et que la police
militaire à kant et oui même je voulais
mais quand on voit où est placée la
police municipale coincée entre un mur
et un marché il n'y a pas d'accès donc
on met des caméras ou retenions
d'ailleurs c'est une image qui est très
significatif c'est à dire que comme on
n'a pas l'habitude d'approcher les gens
dont on les tient à distance avec les
caméras voilà c'est un peu l'image que
j'ai et donc si vous visez monsieur
thibault alors on est classé 6 il est
distant il tient les gens à distance
bah je résume c'est votre interprétation
mais je veux dire que nous ce que vous
avez voulu dire monsieur sarko mais on
met des caméras et ceux qui sont censés
être les représentants et de de la
protection des spiritains les policier
municipal ils sont coincés entre le
marché et un mur d'eau que voilà voilà
c'est l'image l'image que j'ai à la
librairie souhaité fait réagir ne vient
pas souvent au conseil municipal
d'ailleurs il n'a pratiquement jamais
mis les pieds au conseil municipal
depuis six ans s'il venait plus souvent
il aurait su que la vie lui cet esprit a
fait l'acquisition de l'immeuble de
l'ancien nîmes bouclé en face de chez
lolita phase ii du parking des taxis
collectifs pour installer la police
municipale cet immeuble
on en a fait l'acquisition et les
travaux vont commencer très bientôt pour
installer la place municipale
le premier thème
en conseil municipal premier thème la
vie quotidienne donc on rentre là
maintenant vraiment dans le vif du débat
alors on vous pose des questions mais
vous pouvez échanger entre vous avec le
maire sortant mais aussi entre vous
entre vous candidat voilà vous avez une
toux vous téléphone sur silence vous
dites oui c'est alors alain il va vous
poser c'est bien ce que j'aime dans la
vie quotidienne lors des quotidiennes
mais l'homme blanc teint on va parler de
politique sportif et de la jeunesse
quelle vision vous avez de la politique
sportive actuelle
qu'est ce que vous pouvez pour proposer
pour l'améliorer je pense qu'il faut
l'accompagnement l'accompagnement on a
le basket on a le foot on a le volet
donc il faut accompagner ces structures
les accompagner comment il faut les déjà
les écouter pour savoir leurs besoins
parce que on peut faire des pas fait
selon vous allez alger par le nom de
cohésion spirit in je parle au nom de
quoi vous pensez que si vous dites qu'il
faut le faire c'est que vous estimez
peut-être que ce n'est pas la paix ou
pas suffisamment fait c'est une question
que je vous pose alors c'est ma poésie
en gros est ce que l'équipe sortante a
soutenu les associations clubs sportifs
du dans la commune alors je vois qu'à
lui cf
les seniors sont partis on n'a plus la
segnora du cs et accueille les jeunes je
pense qu'effectivement bien accompagné
donc là c'est le club cycliste
tout à fait cs mais vous avez un
cycliste sur votre liste monsieur tir où
il est toujours là mais quel ton amical
ou écologie c'est chez nous à lui c est
donc malades vivent c'est ma
disponibilité pour pouvoir justement
écouter les gens
les accompagner et communiquer ensuite
parce qu'en fait c'est ce qui manque
peut-être que c'est à lui sait s il y
avait ce dialogue il y avait cette
communication
nous aurions gardé nos seniors parce
qu'on avait une très bonne équipe est
pratiquement à toutes les courses
lui c est ce on avait un gagnant parmi
l'union
tant que nous allons les écouter et nous
allons les accompagner mais parce que
les écouter sinon c'est déjà une
première chose il faut laisser surtout
de savoir leurs besoins pour connaître
leurs besoins et après les accompagner
du mieux que nous pouvons nous n'allons
pas pour mettre des merveilles nous ne
connaissons pas la situation financière
de la commune
donc nous ne pouvons pas non plus venir
les plus vendus rêve en leur disant que
non du concret nous accueillent
s'inscrit-elle nous sommes dans le
concret olivier bérisson vous disiez que
l'humain est au centre de votre
programme justement parlant du main et
de politique sportive on parle aussi de
jeunesse votre proposition comment
accompagner ces jeunes comment
accompagner ces associations déjà je
suis pas trop loin de l'âge de la
jeunesse
ce que je veux dire c'est que j'ai été
un peu plus jeunes dans la commune
et donc les activités sportives et
culturelles je connais ce que j étais
engagé très fortement dans quasiment
toutes les associations de la commune
attend que soit deux dirigeants soient
bénévoles trois mêmes sponsors avec les
faibles moyens comme je pouvais même
s'il peut acheter des packs d'eau est un
problème majeur c'est comment nous
considérons et je n'ai pas dit qu'on en
fait que quelque chose à part le
problème est le suivant ce que ce sont
des êtres humains
lorsque nous les mettons au monde ne
voyais pas ça comme un problème
ils nous voient une joie je sais pas
pourquoi tout ce qui fait qu'ils
arrivent à 15 16 17 ans sur tous les
plateaux et pas seulement cet esprit
nous entendons parler des jeunes des
jeunes des jeunes excités quand en
réalité nous avons un problème majeur
avec eux c'est que ils ne sont pas
considérés comme des êtres humains à
part entière
on a l'impression d'être qui sont des
ovnis quand on parle du alors la
première sécurité c'est justement de
faire comme et c'est notre devise amour
si c'est papa si ces moments si ses
soucis ses frères cissé au kimono pas
comporté comme le zouk à metepec moment
d'un chantier de ces notions trois mois
et puis vient l'heure elle si elle
échoue c'est aura vu donc en réalité le
jeune faut pas le prendre pour un con
aujourd'hui avec les moyens
technologiques des réseaux sociaux il à
l'information de crise et n'a fait le
point ce qu'on lui donne mais la réalité
est ce qu on a tenu compte de ce pour
quoi il est doué et est-ce qu'on a
accompagné à ce qu'ils se développent ce
don
donc nous avons des jeunes qui méritent
mieux que seulement passer la
débroussailleuse ou planter des arbustes
avant les périodes électorales
les redevables de politique sportive
justement est ce que dit il ya des
écoutes et sur pour vous mais ce qu'il
faudrait le mettre en place des coûts
tri yann politiques à mettre en place
depuis l'école maternelle publique
riches
j'avais dit que les camps sportifs
doivent doivent entrer automatiquement
obligatoirement dans les écoles moi je
suis je suis extrêmement choquée mais
mes enfants en pratiquant jouer au stade
spirit r
et aux black stars mais pourquoi parce
que évidemment ils ont un pack élite et
sportif mais tous les parents ne le sont
pas forcément
donc automatiquement il faut que en
chaque début d'année scolaire que les
clubs sportifs puissent entrer et au
delà de l'année du début de l'année
scolaire qu'il y ait une programmation
régulière de rencontres entre le corps
enseignant et les clubs sportifs leurs
dirigeants et puis il faut conclure
et puis je pense que les autres j'en
parlais combien de jeunes qui jouent au
stade spirit et qui connaissent 6,3 du
stade hippique
moi je me souviens l'année où j'ai été
dirigeant des u11 ou stabilité
les deux premiers entraînements ma part
ma part je brûle nous pas les 10 stades
de parler d'histoire stade et ça a été
l'une des rares fois où les u11 ont
gagné à la fête patronale le tournoi
devant la france 3 1
pourquoi parce que il avait une âme pas
seulement merci olivier version voilà ok
alors c'est au tour de daniel sainte
rose
concernant justement la politique que
sportive que vous enfin quel regard vous
portez sur ce qui a été fait aux six
dernières années
et puisque vous voulez proposer vous
peut-être de différent la politique
sportive jeunes je ne vais pas les
prendre à partir de de la mandature de
monsieur thibault je crois que j'irai
dans le sens d'olivier vous non on était
en comité du stade par exemple et que le
mercredi vous avez d'aider des parents
qui vous emmènent les enfants
je ne dis pas pour s'en débarrasser mais
pour avoir un peu de liberté et puis
pour que l'enfant ils s'épanouissent un
peu mais sans ça le volet contraignant
pour l'enfant donc ce n'était pas de sa
propre initiative et je pense que il
faut avoir une éducation
le sport doit rentrer dans le cycle de
la scolarité de l'enfant des tout petits
est donc ce n'est pas parce que on à
part on n'a pas d'autres formes de
loisirs ou de distraction
donc on va imposer aux jeunes de faire
du sport moi je pense que c'est ça fait
partie de l'éducation l'imposé mais
c'est vivement conseillé oui c'est
et ses conseillers mais doit pas être
fait sous la contrainte mais quand même
mais je peux vous dire que vous faire du
sport parce que le saint-esprit sipa la
ville est donc dans les campagnes si
vous avez un enfant qui veut faire du
sport vous avez le problème du transport
si l'enfant sinon je ne peux pas faire
du sport vous savez que nous n'avons pas
de transport interurbain donc par
conséquent si votre contrat vous bien
parle de cartes il si votre enfant
habitat va là tout à fond coulisses où
je ne sais quoi et qui veut aller jouer
au foot
bon eh bien il peut pas donc voila voila
l obstacle à la pratique de son sport
fred michel terrot alors beaucoup de
choses à dire tout d'abord pour faire
des choses il faut avoir les moyens
donc on a trouvé la situation
une situation catastrophique au niveau
financier en 2014
situation qui s'est nettement améliorée
depuis que nous sommes là au niveau
sportif
beaucoup de choses ont été faites je ne
veux pas citer tous les équipements qui
ont été faits le stade de compétition
quand même en un stade de compétition
beaucoup de clubs sportifs auraient aimé
avoir un stade de compétition comme le
nôtre l'éclairage du stade de kabyles
nous avons restauré le parcours santé
1km six ans avec deux terrains annexes
qui sont éclairés nous avons construit
le plateau de grand-bassin nous avons un
équipement sportif à l'ambassade grand
passé au fond coulisses monsieur si on
peut jouer au football sans avoir à se
déplacer puisque j'ai fait construire ce
terrain ce plateau sportif à grand
bassin nous avons aussi sur les terrains
annexes installé dit fais ce tiers quand
même parce que jusqu'à ce jour les gens
se baignait les joueurs se baignait sous
le robinet mais ils ont des vestiaires
confortable que m'implanter de l'équipe
de régal utilise régulièrement elle le
sait très bien puisqu'elle est
régulièrement tous les samedis avec eux
donc ça se passe très bien donc tout le
monde est content
je ne parle même pas de la piscine
communautaire ou dont j'ai suivi les
travaux et g j'ai fait en sorte que
après cette première pierre posée en
février 2015 2017 et bien que que cette
piscine soit inaugurée que tout le monde
est content d'avoir une piscine
communautaire au saint-esprit dont les
les travaux ont été faits des
équipements été fait
et au niveau associatif et notamment
pour les clubs sportifs nous
accompagnons malgré les difficultés
financières nous avons maintenu les
financement et l'accompagnement
financier aux associations
plus de 80 3000 euros chacun est
maintenue aux associations quand
d'autres communes supprime ces budgets
nous avons maintenu des sommes
importantes mais nous ne nous contentons
pas de nain accompagnement financier et
un accompagnement administratif
d'accompagnement vous avez maintenu
c'est déjà bien mais non mais n'avait
pas augmenté malgré le contexte
financier difficile monsieur malgré le
contexte financier difficile malgré que
je vous dis 14
nous avons des baisses de dotations du
vallon s'impose avant des baisses de
dotations que toutes les communes
doivent supporter aujourd'hui il y a
également un accompagnement
administratif un accompagnement
logistique puisque les dirigeants aussi
sont accompagnés sur la formation de
dirigeants
on ne peut pas rentrer dans
l'organisation le fonctionnement des
associations puisque chaque association
s'administre elle-même il n'appartient
pas à la municipalité de dire que telle
ou telle de tels clubs ne peut pas aller
d'un tel club comme ça était sous
entendu mais aussi également un
accompagnement de la jeunesse toutes les
personnes jeunes ou moins jeunes
d'ailleurs qu'ils me faut une demande
d'emploi
je ne me contente pas de leur répondre
bien sûr je leur réponds mais je les
reçois à ce jour j'ai reçu 2680
spiritains que ce soit mon bureau que je
me rende sur place aussi quand la
personne est passée j'ai reçu 2680
héritage qui vous sont fait je viens en
est le monsieur de tenir les mains sur
les hanches monsieur caruge j'ai reçu
2680 spirit à mon bureau ou chez eux
parce que je me déplace quand je me
déplace je ne vais pas forcément me
faire voir dans la rue parce qu'on n'est
pas élu pour se faire voir
c'est pas assez
10 dans les années monsieur je dis
simplement que 1 me sery qui veut me
voir il ya aucun problème
56 73 aussi maintenant accessible donc
ayant complété ce que nous faisons
l'accord aux autres des réunions ya pas
exagérer monsieur lavoie merci beaucoup
vous avez en face de vous un ancien
joueur de basket un ancien président de
basket un ancien membre du conseil
d'administration d'une activité et
j'étais présent cap de statistiques a
été muni cipal is et bien je suis à
l'aise pour les sports pour parler
développement et des effets bénéfiques
du sport mais malheureusement pendant
trop longtemps
dès lors que la politique s'incruste
dans le milieu associatif sportif
nigeria prouver mais le meilleur c'est
gentil ici si ma pauvre tant mieux pour
lui
je veux dire que je vais pas remonter au
passé on ne pourra pas refaire
l'histoire mais nous allons devoir tenir
compte de l'histoire par conséquent
maintenant monsieur qui vous me semblez
ya un projet qu'on avait réussi ces
jeunes bouchers des inaugurations seul
et vous vous aimez vous inventez pinceau
d'un seul j'aimerais que vous aimez vous
inventez c'est vous qui le dites
quand vous parlez de la piscine
communautaire pour une fois ce soir
j'entends dire qu'il s'agit d'une
piscine communautaire et notre piscine
municipale
c'est très souvent on doit vous rappeler
qu'il s'agit d'une piscine communautaire
je me demande comment les spirit et
n'ont pas profité de cette piscine je
m'explique les jeunes scolaires
notamment
des skis seulement
pas de la route et moi laissez moi à
développer ces problèmes se livrent les
scolaires spiritains n'ont pas profité
sinon il ya très peu dans la peine deux
mois je m'en explique le
à son geste qui est la structure qui
gère la piscine a envoyé un courrier à
toutes les municipalités vont informer
de l'ouverture de cette piscine
monsieur thibault a répondu que c'est
monsieur mâcon qui a lancé la daj la
piscine pour tous nagé
voilà et comme s'agit de monsieur macro
président il faut qu'il donne de
l'argent et au congrès des maires au
dernier congrès des maires vous avez
participé
vous avez interpellé monsieur mâcon qui
vous a répondu que je n'avais pas fait
de demande qu'on ne peut pas décider à
votre place quand devront nager les
spiritains alors que rivière salée et
rivière pilote n'ont pas attendu les
dotations de l'état
ils ont fait rentrer de l'eau budget
thaddée le budget comment s'appelle le
budget de du service des sports et le
budget du service scolaire
tout ça est rentré dans le budget global
et les avances piloter deux italiens ont
pu nage et ont fait profiter de la
piscine qui sur la scène de centre de 19
janvier vous avez estimé qu'il fallait
faire un gros tas sur la piscine à
saint-esprit ont montré que ça
fonctionnait nous avons une association
la vague spiritaines qui n'a pas pu se
développer comme il le fallait
non non non vous avez répondu madame
plantain veux c'est mourir avant et puis
ensuite vous verrez avec beckham cherche
plus de temps que tout le monde si je
veux arriver on a quatre attendez je ne
sais pas comme ça se confirme ils disent
évidemment
évidemment s'il devrait permettre à
michel joseph cadre à notre rédaction se
chargent du chronométrage et ils
viennent me signaler justement que vous
êtes en avance en temps de parole bah
oui voilà donc mais vous allez répondre
mais évidemment on pouvait pas non plus
maryse plante à intervenir à chaque fois
l'eau je vais dire que la piscine
communautaire
je précise qu'à l'époque j'étais
conseiller municipal et que monsieur
eugène marché est venu en mairie le
conseil municipal d'hier le pourquoi on
avait choisi le cd semi donc
effectivement c'est ici notifié ce soir
c'est tant mieux c'est une piscine
communautaire
ce n'est pas la ville du cd quand
j'entends comme monsieur le maire
sortant dit qu'il a reçu plus de 2000
personnes
mais au rythme de cinq minutes par
personne il peut recevoir dix mille
personnes
parce que c'est ce qu'il fait vous avez
cinq minutes vous avez dix minutes quand
un maire qui est un élu de proximité dit
qu'il n'est pas là pour se faire voir
je suis désolé un maire est un élu de
proximité et nous à cause de spirit m
nous voulons remettre l'humain au centre
pas mettre des caméras ou les surveiller
mais m à côté du pas tous les jours
faire un planning c'est l'engagement que
nous à couiza suit celle que nous
prenons c'est le message que nous
passons lors de nos porte à porte et les
gens sont allés coûte les gens nous le
demande
elodie navarre et voté le projet au
cabinet alors quand je vois une mère en
2014 je fais campagne et je reviens sur
le terrain en 2020 en allant distribués
m mais c'est un manque de respect on ne
peut pas passer chez les gens en 2014
est repassé en 2020 pour moi c'est un
manque de respect c'est pas du m'as tu
vu que d'être là auprès de la population
parce que la population en a besoin
parce que le maire désolé mais c'est son
rôle d'être à côté de la population
alors oui oui et puis ensuite monsieur
tir ou non monsieur monsieur ti ou audi
qui l'a fait construire le plateau
sportif de grand bassin le plateau
sportif de grands bassins étaient en
voie d'achèvement
lors de sa prise de fonction et vous
l'avez ouattar des sciemment pour des
motifs pour des prétextes dérisoire et
et fallacieuse et donc vous avez retardé
pour l'inaugurer même mais si vous avez
le vous avez le rouleau de bleu blanc
rouge
voilà les retarder ce n'est pas son
bureau gère cet aperçu initialement
c'est pas son mot jeunes en vie en main
la vie tout mais il était en voie
d'achèvement et vous savez un certain
nombre de travaux comme par exemple la
pose de la pierre de la piscine a été
retardée parce que les élections
la proximité des élections quelles
élections territoriales de 2014
les sessions posé la première pierre à
cette époque à ça aurait été considérée
comme vous avez une forme 2002 de
propagande dit salima cadeau donc voilà
et donc monsieur tigo n'ai à aucun
moment à l'initiative de la
reconstruction du plateau sportif de
grands bassins ne faut pas dire ces
choses et puis on passera un autre sujet
maintenant des mouches parce qu'il n'ya
même que faupala pallidi miss you hou là
là c'est que c'est le maire sortant
olivier bérisson c'est lui qui a fait
six antennes de l'édilité métallique qui
tenait un train qui tenait un travail
et puis qui sait où les faits bon donc
là actuellement n'ai pas besoin d'argent
pour métisser les colas en collection et
puisque le sportif la caisse et de
volonté pour fêter ça a payé et qu'il
faut de nous appeler et puis faudrait y
arrive bien laver ou moins vivement
jouer tournoi football le matin l'école
a que comme en valais des collecteurs
bassin l'école balle donc sympa autant
c'est important que nous le voulons et à
radio organise et d'y animer comme une
rare et sociales brice hortefeux mettez
tout cas termes d'infrastructures
crouler sous passe à animer comme une
soupe à une volonté parce que c'est pas
le wall di pace won
mais maintenant tu mets entendre maguèye
retient vaut qu'un bon effectivement
avoir vocal pas venu au vélo morale ou à
moonlight
ce débat est différent donc ça c'est un
premier pas pour gabas est vraiment bien
placé
marc a fait partie disséminant qui bat
sa fuite
quand l'équipe et rigueur parce que tu
es limité fosses septiques
ces logements qui étaient là pour
arrêter un football a été faussée
petites lignes en a copié sa parfaite
nous
oumé et puis des feux et hommage au pin
s p jean fred à dubaï qui goût mais etc
etc étaient organisées en journée et ces
deux-là savait que l'équipe et
italyachts t organisé par et la poubelle
à l'harmonie donc nous tes à
l'initiative dit ça donc ça c'est
important
l'optima points à la demie puisque parce
que les magasins font la grandeur
d'esprit il faut que nous parlions ça
pour que c'est nous notre camp connexion
nôtre qui est connecté et puis ça la
commune les faits et puis ça nous les
tanks ayew fait donc en réalité c'est ça
parce qu'on me l'a mené en langage de
proximité volontaire mais manquant pour
1/100 lady à ce que sa maladie tout
simplement m'a dit que nous nions slogan
tous pourris moon
donc grosso modo les anti money les
engrais vigneronne sa qualité en mode
l'alcool et donc nous et mac et conclut
en les avalant merci c'est que font en
fait tous en paix en commune pour que
personne par était sur le chaos fait
mais je pense qu il vraiment pour
conclure la surface sur ce dossier le
rôle du maire c'est bien sûr d'être aux
côtés de sa population
je n'ai jamais quitté le terrain que ce
soit au rendez vous avec les administrés
que ce soit dans les réunions de
quartier on vous puisque puisque les
risques puisque chaque année j'organise
une réunion de quartier ou les amis ce
qu'elles peuvent aussi échanger avec
l'ensemble des conseillers municipaux le
rôle de l'élu aussi c'est de représenter
la population dans les différentes
instances à la des halles à l'eau nf à
la préfecture notamment aux idées et
tous les actions aussi également aux
délégations dernièrement parce que nous
sommes conseillers municipaux mais aussi
conseiller communautaire parce que en
attendant oublie que ces élections
municipales et communautaires dont
l'audition de deux cantons par cette
ville
on parle aussi du bilan en tant que
conseil communautaire la piscine
communautaire donc la piscine
mon bilan pour revenir sur ce que madame
plantait disait il faut aussi vous
présenter la population madame plan sera
pas possible mais attendez non mais on
sent bien vous un témoin je suis je suis
allé je suis heureux je suis allé à la
rs madame plantain en tant que
conseiller territorial était également
éviter avant le directeur général de la
rs ou la construction de l'hôpital n'est
pas venu c'était le 4 février dernier le
jeune homme a le droit d'être jours de
fête s'arrête jamais voit les y avait
moi je leur conseillais pour réserver au
conseil de surveillance de l'hôpital le
20 janvier vous étiez présente on a dit
tout ce qu'on prendre rendez vous avec
le directeur général de la rs tout le
monde était là pour voir monsieur le
directeur zonal de la respon parle de
reconstruction d'hôpital les syndicats
étaient présents
les médecins étaient présents les élus
le rapport ce n'est pas d'être dans la
rue et je vais dans la légende
alors il faut être aux côtés la
population il faut aussi oublier les
plantes ainsi je souhaitais aller
monsieur fred michel tigo que cette
convocation
vous me l'a présenté je n'ai jamais reçu
de convocation
effectivement j'étais à la réunion de
surveillance du 20 janvier
vous aviez dit qu'on ferait une visite à
la grèce j'étais d'accord mais vous ne
m'avez jamais voyez lévitation jamais
alors je veux que vous me prouvez
aujourd'hui quand vous m'avez envoyé
cette invitation et que je n'allais pas
au nourris je ne peux pas accepter ça
je n'ai pas reçu d'invitation peut-être
que vous l'avez fait sciemment
parce que vous avez et éplucher le
dossier pouvoir quand quatre cinq ans je
n'étais pas venu à 3 conseil de
surveillance mais à chaque fois je m'en
excuse
vous avez une équipe municipale vous
n'avez pas algérie et je suis seul
très fort
nous allons poursuivre une mode allongée
de telma les fesses alors comme ça alors
si je vous dis à tous mes rides
qu'est ce que vous me répondez la
chanteuse laisse méditer
elle est spirituelle elle est méritée
c'est ce qu'elle fait c'est pas passé
des nations mais j'aime bien c'est dur à
la dernière fête patronale était écouté
art parce que son manager ne mérite vous
ça vous dit quelque chose
non seulement ça mais elle a commencé
l'occasion de participer à un
anniversaire d'une d'une copine à elle
chez moi au monde bat b puisque j'avais
j'avais mangé retraités parce que je
pense du val je la connais un seau percé
ton amie montrait bien alors penser aux
thématiques tout ça en france les
thématiques qu'elle qu'elle développe
sur ses chansons rejoignent les
thématiques que nous développons en tant
que militant alors c'est la transition
pour parler justement de la politique de
la jeunesse
et c'est vrai qu'on entend fred michel
giraud personnellement j'ai entendu des
spiritains alors pas tous évidemment
mais quelques-uns veut dire que vous
avez dû votre élection en 2014 beaucoup
beaucoup à la jeunesse est vrai que
l'agenais spiritaines vous avez rejoint
mais que vous les auriez oublié
peut-être en cours de mandat pas tous et
vous vous avez dit que vous avez reçu
plein plein de jeunes je crois vous avez
un g10 tous les administrés je ne fais
administrés je ne fais pas fait notre
jeunisme ont déjà le corps du jeune
homme et d'attractions mais mais mais
des personnes informées mais certaines
personnes disent que vous n'avez pas
appuyer tous les projets qui vous
étaient présentés
vous avez ne peut faire un douanier pas
le cas où tout le monde personne n'a
fait l'unanimité
alors c'est quoi votre bilan ce pour la
politique là je me rends nous en ce qui
concerne la jeunesse on catégories
souvent la jeunesse avec le sport la
culture et les problèmes voilà la jolie
venons souvent on associe la jeunesse et
le sport déjà l'emploi déjà bien déjà
les employés les mettre en activité nous
avons nous avons créé un service qui
s'appelle service jeunesse et
développement économique n'avons pas
contenté de nous dire nous l'avons fait
il épousa sociaux efficaces nous
associons la jeunesse et le
développement économique
ce qui veut dire lors qu'est ce qu'il va
dire nous accompagnons individuellement
chaque jeune qui vient voir ce service
personnellement moi j'ai déjà accompagné
plusieurs jeunes non seulement pour
aller chercher du travail
j'en ai déjà trouvé du travail pas
seulement dans les collectivités mais
aussi dans les entreprises privées
qu'elle soit sur le territoire tunisien
dès la soirée passée mal votre fonction
la wii cette fois sur le thème pas de
fonction première du maire qu'elle soit
oui tout à fait effectivement mais
justement mais comme on dit sollicité
souvent vous savez les solliciter pour
plein avec certains peuvent interpréter
ça comme une forme de clientélisme et
plaide pour play de pau plein de
domaines
la mairie a une compétence générale donc
elle peut se saisir à bras le corps
quand elle voit qu'il ya une défaillance
quelque part qu'on ne peut pas reprocher
au maire de s'occuper d'accompagner
jeunes qui recherchent du travail oui
mais de lui trouver un travail c'est
différent je le fais régulièrement nos
services les services le fais
régulièrement et accompagne ce jeune
parce que souvent on voit qu'il ya des
entreprises qui cherchent du travail qui
charge qui cherchent des en ville des
personnes
les employées et des employés qui
cherchent un emploi mais il faut mettre
les gens connexion et aux côtés de pôle
emploi aux côtés de la mission locale au
côté de l'espace sud la mairie notamment
le service développement économique joue
son rôle et notre service joue son rôle
à plein temps
quel sens non mais ça doit le gagner
votre votre vos propositions sur la
jeunesse l'emploi la mise en activité
des jeunes
oui mais il ya un certain nombre de
choses qu'on ne peut pas laisser passer
comme ça monsieur foot michel thibault
dit qu'il oriente les jolies vers les
entreprises privées au saint-esprit mais
j'aurais j'aurais aimé qu'il me suit le
nombre d'entreprises et killer
saint-esprit parce que monsieur foot
michel thibault l'image de synthèse mais
je vais vous donner une image
il vient de parler de l'hôpital à
l'instant il est le responsable qui
siège au conseil d'administration au
conseil de surveillance un hôpital
défaillant qui est devenu le nepad labos
qui n'existe plus vous regardez bien
l'image c'est très imagé le côté sombre
de ce que vivent les spiritains un
hôpital défaillant vous avez trois
cabinets d'infirmières autant de
médecins autant de kiné et vous avez
vous terminé trois entreprises de pompes
funèbres
alors voilà l'image funeste que
représente le saint-esprit et quand
comme celui-ci on ne connaît pas sa
commune quand il dit qu'il dirige les
jeunes vers des entreprises privées mais
qu'il ment site qu'il n'en cite une
entreprise qu'il me cite une reprise
biais négatif mais on n'est pas les 4 6
ans directeur du bic à b ou mode la
valeur m'a appelé et j'ai revenir
c'est dommage alors voilà ce que je veux
dire que quand vous avez ce qu'on
appelle l'entreprise au saint-esprit
vous avez des activités de services mais
où sont les commerces où sont les
commerces vous rendez compte
j'ai déjà tout cela on était sur la
jeunesse il y en a qui l'a mise en place
un organisme enfin un outil
je suis comme on vous l'avait appelé en
conseil service jeunesse développement
la service jeunesse et développement
économique bon ça voulu lui accorder ce
n'est pas tant les effets ne sont pas
visibles donc pas très efficient qu'est
ce que vous avez comme proposition vous
de survenue de ce point de vue là vous
parlez sur la jeunesse oui écoutez je ne
veux pas faire offense à la jeunesse
nous avons des nous avons des jeunes qui
sont très diplômés du bac + mais il y a
il ya quelque chose c'est à dire que la
maturité c'est à dire qu'ils sont
précoces en études en matière diplomate
simplement ils ont besoin de cet
accompagnement c'est à dire que ils
n'ont pas la maturité nécessaire d'aller
d'aller chercher et aidons donc vite il
faut il à quoi devrait servir non mais
les services qu est ce qu un
accompagnement mais il faut il dit la
fille ou non mais il vous faut mais je
vous dis qu'on n'a pas vu les effets
mais il fonctionne autrement il vous
faut une structure d'orientation parce
que la commune ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
un pourvoyeur de demandeurs d'emploi
dont il vous faut il vous faut des
structures d'orientation pour aider ces
jeunes je parlais de même maturité les
bosquets et s'ils ne peuvent pas
constituer un dossier
il faut cet accompagnement là donc il
vous faut les techniciens et cela aux
saintais c'qui le le rapport humain il
vous faut un drh la notion humaine le
saint-esprit les notamment concernant le
merci monsieur miguet
alors sur ce thème de la jeunesse de
l'emploi de la mise en activité des
jeunes
alors contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur triaud à saint-esprit de boot
nous ne stigmatisons par les jeunes dans
le le coupé des autres
moi je dis qu'il n'ya pas de sot métier
il ya des petits métiers qui permettent
aux gens de s'exercer devoir localité et
pourquoi pas de vous des entreprises moi
je retiens que nous sommes effectivement
dans l'élection municipale et
communautaire et on ne dit pas assez
on y voit pas assez la mission locale du
sud qui est la peau aussi accompagner
les jeunes et le saint-esprit doit
pouvoir donner l'information transport
transmettre l'information à ses jeunes
quant à l'existence de cette structure
il ya l'école de la deuxième chance à
régler à salé il fonctionne très bien
qui a fait ses preuves sur fort de
france aussi mais cette jeunesse avant
d'avoir travaillé j'étais jeune mais
j'ai fait du sport le sport contribue et
participe au lien social à former les
gens à échanger des expériences et je
vous assure
ayant été ancien responsable sportif
mais je crois que j'ai évité à beaucoup
de générations de se retrouver dans la
rue surtout quand vous êtes en place et
que vous ne servait pas les intérêts de
la collectivité en place on venait de
fusiller alors que je pense qu'il faut
aller vers ces jeunes ne pas avoir peur
d'avoir un langage avec eux très fort
entre fun parce qu'ils sont justement
comment parle d'une maturité
ab c'est ça aussi parce que très souvent
les mères haut les conseils municipaux
ont peur d'aller vers eux parce que
monde je me répète endroit si mardi aux
métis mac ipod envoie ses mâts pales
d'une telle façon pour mais ils en ont
besoin est mais d'avoir des expériences
avec eux on échange et clairement où
finalement ils me disent benjamin six
mois au début à marcq en baroeul a
autrement
donc on ne peut pas laisser dire qu'il
ya une stigmatisation qui est faite sous
les jeunes
parfois que la prévention il faut la
faire parce que la force d'un pays c'est
pas son exposé de la banane ou autre
c'est d'abord la bonne santé de sa
population
la prévention est même illégal dit que
je reviens parce que fred michel terrot
c'est bon peut-être pas en orgueil mais
en tout cas il a vanté son service là
qu'il a mis en place donc décidément je
ne me rappelle pas du service jeunesse
développement économique
écoutez vous êtes au courant si riche
que vous avez rencontrées vous en ont
parlé
écoutez monsieur toujours édition avoir
de plein de choses et s'est vanté
d'avoir reçu 2695 mais écoutez je
pourrais me vanter du nombre de
personnes qui ont attendu jusqu'à
présent deux rendez vous qui l'avez
donné on attend toujours ses visites
dans ce jeu de chiffres ou des résultats
madame plantain alors sur real jeunesse
alors concernant je suis sûr que ce
service
je souhaiterais savoir si un bilan et à
quel niveau ces jeunes woods s'est
accompagnée et comment ils l'oit y est
ce qu y at-il un bilan mais il l'a dit
tout à l'heure des bilans le bilan
chiffré quel bilan aux jeunes
accompagnés combien de jeux répond aux
questions des journalistes mais pas
encore dix autres candidats alors donc
il faut venir mais confiance madame
plantain vous aurez le bilan détaillé je
ne vais pas gaspiller mon temps
ces montants la possibilité d'échanger
en trouver non bien sûr maintenant si je
caractère de l'émission de plaies par
monsieur thibault je ne peux rien non
c'est à dire que le temps le temps des
troubles
c'est inaudible non madame a pas
d'accord et puis ça finit ferrari soit
fini non a répondu non nous détaille
audine l'anne candies présenter des
spirit et nous conte et met pas d'accord
d'ici là ça veut dire pas dit que ces
vignes en ont fait un soupçon view
coincé au tc méprisant et si c'est comme
ça m a coupé un coude si nous partons
tous et beretta de ce quartier ça veut
dire qu'il ya problème majeur la parole
de tamaris plantes vous pourrez
intervenir et la noise un problème de
culture de sport c'est à dire que la
avait voilà il ya des gens qui sont en
rencontre une rencontre sportive
rencontre eh bien quelle est la culture
comment nous nous parlons entre nous
comment nous sommes
antoine lier véritable problème est là
je tiens à souligner alors en parlant de
culture fred michel terrot vous avez dit
j'ai noté un en début d'émission ou dans
des interviews précédente que vous avez
engagé une dynamique culturelle et pour
la ville que vous avez redynamiser au
plan culturel la ville donnez nous des
nouvelles enfin surtout au spirit et néo
spiritains de la salle de spectacle le
congrès sa hausse alors qui donc est
fermé depuis quelques temps je crois est
inactif
ça fait plus de 17 ans oui + 17 ans mais
oui mais au cours des six dernières
années aussi mais attendez
ma question donc du coup le congrès se
nomme n'étant pas ouverts et c'est ce
qu'il y à un lieu de diffusion
artistique et culturelle digne de ce nom
à certains la dynamique culturelle ne
repose pas que sur le congrès salons
congrès c'est parce que j'ai dit est
fermé depuis pas mal d'années parce
qu'il ya un procès qui a commencé depuis
17 ans qui a été initiée entre dans
cette municipalité et l'ancien
gestionnaire de cette salle qui
n'étaient pas d'accord et ce procès a
duré plus de 17 ans ce procès vienne
s'achever issa pouye s'achever ya moins
de quatre mois
par le succès de la ville puisque il
faut savoir que l'ancien gestionnaire
réclamait 4 millions d'euros de dommages
intérêts à la ville qui avait résilié le
contrat de façon abusive ça c'était la
position de l'ancien prestataire en ce
qui concerne la dynamique culturelle
nous n'avons pas attendu pour sur la
médiathèque la médiathèque quand on est
arrivés en 2014 il était fermé je
rappelle que le bâtiment est terminée
depuis 2008
entre 2008 et 2014 rien n'a bougé
il n'y avait pas une chaise une table
livre le support numérique dans cette
médiathèque en 2014
nous avons dû mettre en place la
politique documentaire acheter le
mobilier former le personnel acheter des
supports et mettre en place cette
médiathèque qui était inaugurée en
septembre 2014 il y avait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une semaine où
cet esprit sans qu'il y ait un événement
culturel une manifestation une
présentation de livres une activité
culturelle par laser profil ils exigent
l'arrêt de tradition pas du tout ne
s'était pas dans un arbre ce non pas du
tout c'était pas bien trop bas mais non
pas du tout
le musée il existe depuis longtemps il
n'y a pas de projet ils existent depuis
longtemps
l'invitation de réouverture de la salle
de spectacle le musée ils étaient
installés dans la salle de spectacle
salle de spectacle qui s'est abîmé et
notre projet aujourd'hui que le procès
est terminé on n'a pas faire on va pas
réhabiliter ce bâtiment qui en procès et
dont on ne connaît pas le devenir
aujourd'hui que le procès est terminé
nous pouvons il s'assied sera l'objet de
deux jeunes éléments de notre programme
à partir de 2020 donc de réhabiliter
cette salle de spectacle puisque nous en
avons retrouvé la jouissance hélas hélas
la pleine possession pour pouvoir
réhabiliter cette salle est donnée
notamment une acoustique peut-être
donner un autre nom aussi bien sûr
c'était le nom qui était donné par lens
et prestataires non c'est prévu on vous
sait d'un autre c'est ainsi d'un autre
dans notre projet
vidéo tout à fait je souhaite intervenir
leur guise et elle pas la mise et la
seule de ce spectacle 17 ans un métier
open open sam était de 17 cents ça
m'interpelle
donc je donne pas de réponse je vais je
vais vous la donner dans une prochaine
émission
alors le musée d'art ses serments nous
sommes tristes ou cédées selon les
sources a fait 2003 je crois si on
compte sur un total de 1300 le musée
d'art à couiza speeding nous sommes
tristes
il est passé ou alors c'est balisé les
to get viennent appareil photo en main
encore sam dire il est il se trouve ou
le musée le musée est inexistant enlevez
la balise au moins au moins ou fait
mettre à jour le document le guide
touristique parce que les gens aiment le
club doubiste musée d'art et de
traditions cet esprit est à peine midi
alors je dis que c'est un manque de
communication alors pourquoi fallu que
la culture la médiathèque la
communication non plus n'est pas beau
lien gros problèmes de communication au
niveau de l'équipe et pour moi je vais
pas dire qu'elle est nulle
mêlez pas suffisante
tout le monde n'a pas facebook tout le
monde n'a pas internet
c'est sous les réseaux sociaux qu'on
reçoit les messages mettre des panneaux
à l'entrée des établissements scolaires
ce soir parce qu'il ya effectivement des
choses et rsa pour les enfants mais la
communication ne passe pas comment ces
gens là peuvent venir la communication
elle n'est pas suffisante
donc et puis est-ce que animer une
combine culturellement c'est uniquement
des histoires où les eaux fort la
médiathèque le bachata non je suis
désolé
est ce que c'est à la veille des
élections faire venir jacob desvarieux
qui s'est moqué du public pour je le
sais combien d'argent et ses salles je
ne sais pas est ce que c'est parce qu'il
ya une parade comme dans toutes les
communes alors merci je crois que il
faut oui vous allez rire
alors des mygales duval mais en revanche
je suis obligée de vous demander d'être
un peu plus court s'il vous plaît dans
vos interventions
alain livory tient vraiment à parler un
peu d'agriculture aussi parce que c'est
un port oui voilà
et ensuite il aurait vos conclusions
donc et ça se termine de quasiment 15
minutes donc miguel du valais puis
ensuite daniel sainte rose je remercie
qu'il ya des élections à synthèse peu
pour savoir qui avait poussé qui avait
été gagné et qui avait un soupçon de
projets pour cette salle là encore il ya
des pommes de communication donc tandis
que la vie elle est faite d'opportunités
qu'on va saisir pour pouvoir faire
miroiter des personnes vous avez parlé
aussi de m ce n'est pas le sujet culture
de la grille du de alors la médiathèque
c'est vrai qu'elle fonctionne mais j'ai
la chance d'habiter à proximité d'une
médiathèque et ça quand je rentre chez
moi je sais qu'il y à quelque chose il y
a une méthode publicitaire qui existait
avant dans les communes une voiture qui
passe elle avec des cornières dessus ça
se fait encore incertaine dans certaines
n'est pas sain d'esprit on passait dans
les quartiers on prenait son temps on
annonçait les manifestations et les gens
rapatriés parce que effectivement tout
le monde n'a pas accès à internet nous
ne sommes pas équipés dans les quartiers
de haut débit du coup c'est un peu
élitiste ce qui ferait contre la
médiathèque c'est ça voulait dire c'est
ceux qui ont écouté je vais pas là je
souhaitais d'avoir une générosité c'est
une question de jugement je ne suis pas
sûr non je vais pas dire qu'il ya une
volonté affichée l'accord de distinguer
les personnes pas parce que nous nous
sommes là pour vous faire explicite et
surtout enseignants sous contrôle je
parle je demande de préciser votre coach
aurait pas beaucoup je veux dire qu'il
ya d'autres comme moyen de communication
qui ont été supplantés par la
technologie
il faudrait y penser pour pouvoir
rectifier le tir à ce niveau c'est tout
ce que je dis france 03 qu'il faut qu'il
y ait un rendement et une communication
qui est performant que nous utilisons et
tous les spiritains peuvent s'inscrire
il appelle simplement le standard de la
mairie 56 61 02 fixe
et s'ils le souhaitent ils reçoivent
toutes les activités de la médiathèque
et de la ville par sms il suffit de
donner leur numéro de téléphone et ils
reçoivent un sms ville où cet esprit ils
savent toutes les activités qui se passe
tous les personnes de plus de 13 ans à
peu près 95 % des gens de plus de 13 ans
ont un portable en martinique
donc c'est un moyen de communication et
de temps en temps si on utilise toujours
la voiture sunu quand il ya de grands
événements mais on utilise aussi
beaucoup les sms face vous êtes en
avance à daniel st trop' a ensuite
olivier bérisson et puis on passe à
l'agriculture voilà voilà voilà encore
une méthode une méthode et le dédain
très affichée du maire de dire qu'on
communique par sms et par téléphone
alors on oublie qu'on a eu pendant une
moyenne de personnes âgées qui n'ont pas
accès aux médias modernes et et vous
leur dites que pour pouvoir d
information séparée sms que vous
communiquez avec eux bon voilà je
voulais revenir sur un point g ou
rectifier un pauvre de moi de dire que
la communauté pas pourvoyeur d'emplois
ce que je voulais dire c'est que la
commune crée les dispositions
nécessaires pour que les entreprises
s'installent parce que il n'ya pas
d'investissement public au saint-esprit
et je veux pour preuve comme monsieur
thibault dit qu'il fait pour les jeunes
il use de son droit de préemption et je
pouvais dire abus de préemption il ya
aussi que je connais très bien le le bar
chez de l'an et l'hôtel
l'hôtel-restaurant ya un jeune qui
voulait s'installer et tous ces
documents notariale banque était prêt et
monsieur thibault a usé de son droit de
son habit de préemption quand il parle
de la maison boclé aussi parce qu'il
faut savoir que eux se doit de
préemption pour quoi elle est faite
parce que on disperse partout tous les
services de la municipalité au
saint-esprit sont dispensés mais dans
tout son éclat texas ont éclaté partout
dans la ville voilà je ferme ce point là
donc je voulais dire que j'ai rectifié
mon propos de quand je disais que
l'accord signé par ok
pourquoi la rapide en 2 minutes vous
lire allons vraiment olivier bérisson en
moins d'une minute sur la vire sur la
jonction geneviève allure les lieux de
diffusion géré les événements culturels
ne font pas la culture la culture de
s'inscrire dans une programmatique
humaine
ça veut dire que des pizzas main l'année
il faut qu'ils savent en a qui sait ni
écouté ni écoutés car ali et qui ça
écarts alimentaires
donc ça c'est ça c'est notre projet je
voudrais dire que quand j'entends par
lies the city où je suis plus qu'inquiet
il faut appeler pour avoir servi et il
n'a pas compris que c'est la
municipalité qui doit aller vers les
gens et par les gens qui donnent un
livre la municipalité tadic d'ordre dans
tout le propos qu'il tient et à sept
véhicules aux chroniques avons fait en
sorte que les gens viennent et ça c'est
peut être une déformation
professionnelle mais il là il faut que
ça soit nous et c'est tout ça et c'est
ça tout moun semoun nous irons vers les
gens parce que nous sommes élus pour ça
voilà les alors nous allons parler donc
de l'agriculture quelle est la situation
des agriculteurs spiritains qu'est ce
que vous avez comme proposition pour ces
agriculteurs et est-ce que vous avez est
ce que vous il ya des diagnostics des
terres pour savoir s'il ya du
chlordécone ou pas on arrive plantain
d'abord alors c'est dans le projet de ce
projet sur la culture de nos projets
sont finalisés nous avons des
agriculteurs averti dans l'équipe qui a
travaillé le sujet ni nous allons fait
le sujet ça veut dire quoi quelles
propositions concrètes vous faites alors
faire le recensement comme vous dites
des terres contaminées accompagner les
agriculteurs
parce qu'effectivement de ses eaux
contaminées mais on peut faire d'autres
cultures donc différent foutiez ceux qui
sont qu'ils répondent aux conditions une
culture scène une agriculture saine
pardon à parle du marché parce que vous
savez que nous avons supermarché qui
malheureusement a perdu de sa superbe
parce que il a et il a remplacé l'église
pendant plus d'une dizaine d'années ce
qui fait que nos marges sont deux sont
partis ailleurs et que notre marché est
vide la culture dominante
la production je veux dire agricole
dominante à saint-esprit est ce qu'il
faut selon vous à encourager accompagner
davantage la diversification alors c'est
notre projet c'est de recenser les
agriculteurs les recevoir et savoir
comment les accompagner parce que comme
je parlais du marché pourquoi j'ai parlé
du marché il faut que ce marché-là
vivant il ne vivra pas commis avait
temps mais nous avons des agricultures
et en fonction de leur culture
nous allons faire des deux comédiens des
journées par exemple à thème
moi je connais pas la périodicité ideam
sutil lebon donc on va voir avec eux
donc c'est en les réunissant qu'on saura
la périodicité et nous feront revivre
notre marché justement à travers nos
agricultures et nous allons travailler
avec deux concerts les accompagner des
polices il faut mais nous avons un
projet ficelé parce que nous avons des
agriculteurs qui font de l'agriculture
c'est miguel duval sur l'agriculture
alors cet esprit beaucoup de cannes
beaucoup de mana vient aussi certains
marchés
mais j'ai eu la chance de participer à
un exposé sur le t3 martin kelly
seulement et mickey et cet aspect nous
sommes très argileux mais surtout très
ferrugineux par conséquent spécialiste
de la mode
il est recommandé d'en planter et
d'ailleurs sa flore c'est vrai comme son
clone claude conique nous n'échappons
pas sur clio malheureusement ces thèmes
est landais ou des bananiers
ce bouquin commandant recommandons aux
gens de ne pas dilapider le tir parce
que c'est clos de comics
aujourd'hui nous savons très bien qu'il
ya d'autres cultures de substitution
il est établi aujourd'hui
scientifiquement que la sève ne va pas
tout autre univers l'euro et donc il
faut respecter ça maintenant nous avons
aussi la chance au bon que beaucoup de
maisons soient dotés de bouts de terrain
ça ne paraît pas mais je vous dit un
grand parti de maison nous avons des
terres et nous inciterons les personnes
à développer ce qu'ils peuvent manger
immédiatement et si prévenir un bon état
de santé aussi
maintenant nous allons aussi nous allons
aussi et ça je peux le nommer parce que
la paix seulement autorisé à le nommer
je parle de monsieur qu'on appelle japon
fils qui intervient au niveau des
structures de formation agricole
équiperait et qui pourrait apporter son
savoir à contribuer à un lien très
étroit entre les agriculteurs et les
structures d'information alors la
merveilleuse elle s'impose alors au
début on avait dit on nous a présenté
comme un agriculteur je suis à la
retraite en fermant fenêtres a déclaré
professionnellement comme agriculteur
mais vous faites quand même de
l'agriculture que oui je continue en
amateur je connais le problème de
l'agriculture puisque j'ai j'ai été j'ai
eu des responsabilités dans des
organisations professionnelles j'ai été
lui de la chambre d'agriculture on quand
on parle d'agriculture
c'était un faux partie faux partis d'eux
parce qu'on a parlé du marché le marché
c'est la finalité
la société a changé donc là la finalité
le marché dans son option dans son
fonctionnement actuel ne donne elle ne
doit pas exister parce que il n'y a pas
de production
vous avez un marché sans production donc
l'intérêt est ce que j'ai réfléchi c'est
à dire que les jardins familiaux
quand on parle d'agriculture aussi il
faut parler de revenus nous parlons
d'agriculture mais ne parlons pas
l'agriculteur il faut parler de revenu
et d'en parler aussi de santé d'autres
enfants détestent parce que il faut que
tous déjà soit dissous le chlordécone
parce que je vous dis une chose je sujet
j'étais juste dans la banane et la
proximité tout autour de moi il ya une
cartographie qui est sorti mais je n'ai
jamais vu personne faire de prélèvement
ni chez moi ni chez les actions des
agriculteurs violents alors qu'il ya une
cartographie non mais c'est une c'est
une réalité
donc il ya beaucoup de produits au sort
qu'on peut faire ce que je disais il ya
les jardins créoles les jardins
familiaux
est ce que je propose que ces personnes
qu'il y ait une extension de leur
production et que le refus ou plus que
nous ayons que nous allons mettre en
place une organisation une structure de
2,2 de récupération d'approvisionnement
et de trouver les éléments nécessaires
pour que ce produit soit diffusée soit
vendu dans un périmètre pour qu'il n'y
ait pas d'intermédiaire et queue leu leu
l'agriculture en général et la totalité
de son revenu et et pardon et j'ai une
petite parenthèse et je crois que c'est
très important non non les phrases
malheur nous soyons mitoyen du bac
lamoise aujourd'hui bien mitoyen et que
nous n'avons pas accès à l'irrigation au
saint-esprit et je crois que là le
niveau d'intervention vous reprocher ni
donc je parle de niveau la capacité
d'influencé d'intervention serait auprès
de la ctm et auprès de l'espace sud pour
que cette chose là se fasse alors fois
de michel terrot sur l'agriculture alors
l'initiative du maire du prêcheur qui a
pris une motion contre l'utilisation de
pesticides sur son territoire pour une
agriculture saine l'agriculture
biologique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez sans
pesticides sur une bonne initiative
interdisant les pc une bonne initiative
je rappelle que la vie lui saint-esprit
un label trois feuilles et trois fleurs
c'est à dire quelques labels 3 3
feuilles ça fait donc deux ans que nous
n'utilisons plus de pesticides nous un
municipalité pour l'entretien de nos
jardins des espaces verts donc bien
évidemment c'est une bonne initiative et
et ce serait bien que tous les
agriculteurs s'ils le peuvent parce
qu'aussi c'est facile de le dire mais il
faut aussi pouvoir parce que les
pesticides parfois ça peut ce que nous
faisons tout cas nous sortir de nos déjà
exaucé rapide en tout cas au niveau de
la municipalité
en ce qui concerne l'agriculture
effectivement monsieur sainte rose a
parlé de de chlordécone oui il existe
effectivement une cartographie puisque
les agriculteurs sont accompagnés par
chambre d'agriculture et la fredon pour
faire des tests et des prélèvements et
on a effectivement une cartographie de
la ville
cette cartographie et de la martinique
d'ailleurs peut se retrouver sur le site
de l' ars agence régionale de santé nous
un autre niveau en ce qui concerne les
jardins familiaux nous accompagnons
puisque d'accompagnants la population à
avoir ce réflexe là puisque nous avons
mis en place un atelier du si c'est ce
qui s'appelle un atelier agro jardinage
agro écologiques qui est très suivie et
pourrait inciter la population que ce
soit dans le bois la campagne aussi à
faire ces gestes-là
d'autres éléments ont été réalisés par
notre municipalité pour accompagner les
agriculteurs
il ya beaucoup de fonds européen qui
existe mais malheureusement souvent ils
ne savent pas comment les mobiliser et
c'est pour cette raison que notre
service jeunesse développement
économique dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure a organisé plusieurs sessions de
formation notamment pour les
agriculteurs pour pouvoir utiliser ces
fonds européens
parce qu'il existe y sont ils sont ils
sont assez importants et si ces mêmes
fois européens que nous nous allons
mobiliser pour désenclaver les
agriculteurs nous allons d'ailleurs
commencer très prochainement par la
route régale à nos routes qui dont on
parle depuis des années qui était percé
mais qui n'est pas encore né pas encore
bien mobile dans un plat sans quelques
quelques lignes qu en quelques mots je
veux dire qu'on a fait quelque chose
d'important plus agriculture puisque
nous avons au cours de la dernière
mandature réviser de façon générale
notre plan local d'urbanisme
il ya une disposition que nous avons
prises qui est quand même une première
martinique c'est que nous avons permis
aux agriculteurs de compléter leurs
revenus
parce qu'ils vont faire de
l'agritourisme avec en installant sur
sur leurs terrains agricoles des
habitations légères de loisirs ou des
mobil-home ou faire de la vie twizy ils
sont possibles une diversification
voiles et voiliers la diversification
est excellent de laghouat est ce que ça
reste toujours mal année cannes culture
dominante ou il ya de la maladie et du
maraîchage il appartient aussi aux
agriculteurs c'est pas à la municipalité
de décider ce que les avis de noront
faire saigner l'on peut impulser
c'est ce que nous faisons a souhaité que
c'est ce que nous faisons et si ce que
le pmu prix voix nous sommes là pour
accompagner les agriculteurs
olivier mais lens venait nous avons
terminé sur l'agriculture non le solide
au service non mais vous êtes déterminés
et bien finalement contrôlé donnent un
bon signal
en dix minutes de 37,1 alors c'est vrai
vous êtes le maire sortant et que
quelques barons de comprendre on peut
répondre mais nous notre rôle c'est que
vous ne dépassez pas non plus trop de
minutes excédentaires par rapport aux
autres
voyez c'est notre souci mygale du valais
puis ensuite olivier berruyer
c'est vrai monsieur thibault vient de
parler du pub mais là encore un c'est à
la veille des élections il ya eu
beaucoup de va-et-vient la mairie il
fallait que ça soit électoralistes en
dire que le calcul a été fait pour
parler de continuité alors que beaucoup
d'habitants ont reçu un courrier type
moi je les ai reçus aussi d'autres
personnes ont reçu on vous dit qu'en
dépit de ces ya un peu de cela vous ne
pouvez rien faire
et puis brusquement là comme j'ai mis le
pied dans le plat concernant la cité au
légal concernent des titres de propriété
et qu'on veut et union se fait au
quartier régale avec les habitants alors
que pendant longtemps ces pédants loyer
s'agissait de d'habitation l es nouvel
outil de mobilité des personnes m'ont
dit même occasion voudrait aller
ailleurs mais en vendant ici j'aurais pu
investir ailleurs
mais malheureusement avec le défaut de
titre de propriété
mais c'est parti sur la tête monsieur
thibault sinon c'est remettre en cause
les déclarations des habitants il faut
les respecter on vous l'a déjà dit il ya
un tir d'ariane qui soit le cml ajaccio
2-0 suscite personne à la mairie
c'était pas très conviviale pour eux
pourquoi ils sont venus récemment voici
ce qu'on vous dit laquelle vous fait
défaut et vous n'avez pas l'air de le
comprendre car malade et les gens entre
votre service et lavaur le cv du latex
général il faut comprendre
l'exaspération des personnes alors
maintenant comme j'ai mis le pied dans
le plat ici même dans vos studios
monsieur monsieur carouge branle bas de
combat vous avez organisé une grande une
grande réunion alastair égal avec eux ok
alors olivier bérisson sur l'agriculture
c'est trop long s'il vous plaît oui
parce que les grilles dit oui non mais
je voudrais trop longs voilà c'est tout
c'est moi qui répondait à ce que je la
remarque je vous faisais sur
l'agriculture déjà dit spirit et savent
comme tout à chacun que je suis un
combattant et qui s'est acharné il sans
aucun élu sans aucun élu pour qu'un
directeur martiniquais soit conservée à
la tête du lycée agricole de paris v on
n'a vu personne
bon donc pourquoi parce que c'est comme
dirait aliker seuls les martiniquais
peuvent s'occuper de la martinique
donc ça c'est déjà premier point
deuxième point donc nous nous battons
c'est déjà arrivé que des jeunes cet
esprit fasse appel à moi pour simplement
pouvoir travailler vous me posez une
question mais vous n'écoutez pas me
suivait si je vous exhorte on est en
train de dire de sa doit surtout
composer d'un supplémentaires a dit on
les fait déjà débat qu'est-ce que vous
avez assez du temps si ça pourrit pneus
mais ça coûte et tout moulin la lorraine
non mais ils vous avez la politesse
d'écouter tout le monde mais on vous
attend dans ces écoutes
donc ce que je disais parce que c'est
très difficile de parler de club qui
parlent entre eux et qui m'a posé une
question donc voulons comprendre si
c'était vous c'est ça le truc en 2006
c'était ou que ce taux grimpe
bon voilà donc voilà donc c'est ça et
donc on doit aller donc c'est ça ben là
c'est sympa de nous raconte vivent
ensemble et oui monsieur brice o'hara
mais c'est ça la culture du jeu
ressemble déjà eu à matteo pelli
parce qu'ils ont du mal déjà à trouver
des terrains à des jeunes qui ont des
formations qui sont diplômés et qui
veulent travailler
il y en a qui veut qu'il veut faire une
ferme avec des animaux ans il a toutes
les difficultés du monde à simplement
traverser un chemin existant depuis
mathusalem est connu partout les spirit
et parce que monsieur est venu acheter
une propriété dit il se dit syndicaliste
depuis 30 ans d'ailleurs ce monsieur et
puis mettez en chine les pires empêché
google a passé le k perdu des animaux
qu'il a acheté il a perdu des agneaux de
l'acheter nous à moon
évidemment qu'on va mettre en présence
les deux personnes parce qu'il s'agit de
faire quoi un jeune qui veut travailler
un jeune qui veut persévérer on ne va
pas faire de côté par là de côté par
l'impôt comme a dit le guen que fosse
aux mondiaux nous papeete voix nous la
seule voie qui nous intéresse c'est le
sait que justement déjà pu exprimer leur
talent et voici un talent pour l'instant
qui relativement bloqués c'est vrai
parce que monsieur en chine évidemment
si l'on écouté les démarches ont indiqué
les appétits bon alors alors non 1 500
premiers points wii deuxième point le 2e
2e pas jusqu'à 20h20 deuxième fois 2e
puis je vous en prie dans une enveloppe
alors déjà loués
évidemment quand il faut aller vers le
zéro pesticide vous savez bien que le
militant je suis les spiritueux savent
donc c'est important
nous savons aujourd'hui que les lits les
perturbateurs endocriniens contenues
dans les pesticides change l'identité
sexuelle ont des répercussions sur les
capacités intellectuelles physiques et
comique olivier bérisson qu'on va pas
faire un développement aussi ce qui est
devant vous ce que vous avez comme
projet l'accroché projets pour
développer l'agriculture à sa déjà le
fonds versés bon c'est faire en sorte
que les jeunes puissent s'installer que
je sais faire en sorte que d'aider les
agriculteurs qui sont âgés puissent
transmettre il nous avons contre une
agriculture hier avant-hier au pied du
monde bat b qui a privé temps pour
pouvoir trouver un jeune pour pouvoir
transmettre d'autres
donc voilà nous sommes obligés de
conclure voilà donc sa gestion des lieux
accompagné que les gens se rencontrent
et vierzon et jean fin gourmet et un
moment l'information des jeunes je vous
remercie
avant lui
on attendait j'ai une question alain
ivory passe comme ça l'an zéro g
monsieur bérisson pour sa présentation
de candidature qui ai je demandé ce
qu'il pensait du bilan de l'équipe
sortante et du maire sortant fred michel
tir haut il m'a répondu par cette
boutade mais tous les alors peut-être
certains spirit et avait saisi la
subtilité du propos mais beaucoup de
peut-être martiniquaise et martiniquais
qui n'habitent pas cet esprit ne
s'arrête pas et il m'a répondu il n'y a
pas eu de montgolfières donc je lui ai
demandé après ce qu'il a voulu dire
il m'a dit bon les spiritains
comprendront et cetera fred michel
terrot ça vous dit quelque chose que
monsieur bérisson 10 comme ça il a dit
que vous aviez promis une montgolfière à
cet esprit non en 2014 lors de votre
campagne électorale ça vous fait sourire
c'est pas dans notre programme c'est à
dire que c'est donc 2014 vous avez parlé
une golf n'était pas dans notre
programme écrit dans la déco 10 tickets
doral pas écrit à des policiers qui
avaient parlé effectivement de faire des
ballons captifs ou non pour faire venir
des touristes mais techniquement c'est
compliqué de faire des ballons par
montgolfier à cause des alizés donc il
faudrait faire un ballon captif
donc c'est techniquement cela par les
gens voulaient parler je sais que ça ne
veut parler du musée je pense je pense
que ces deux a noté voulez parlez pas
des confusions légal jauzion laissés en
conclusion alors c'est olivier bérisson
qu'il termine l'exercice est on va
commencer mais vous saviez la parole
monsieur fred michel thibault on va
commencer par vous eh bien je dis aux
spiritains que on a fait un travail
qu'ils voient qu'ils nous remarque tous
les jours on est assaini les finances un
peu de la ville puisque nous étions dans
une situation difficile aujourd'hui nous
avons les écoles qui sont aux normes
il faut rappeler qu on avait quand même
trois écoles sur sept qui n'étaient pas
aux normes du travail a été fait malgré
un contexte difficile
nous demandons à la population de nous
faire confiance pour poursuivre le
travail puisque nous avons des projets
importants
nous les invitons à suivre nos réunions
de quartier où on explique ce qui a été
fait et ce qu'on souhaite faire
et donc je les invite d'ores et déjà à
la prochaine réunion de quartier qu aura
au moins neuf ans mercredi prochain à
18h30 chez madame berger juste à côté de
chez madame mongai un moment devant et
puis vendredi prochain ce vendredi au
mans de la valeur comme ça on va pouvoir
échanger et discuter sur les projets que
nous avons voilà daniels a330 oui elle
nous voulons l'alliance des forces
puritaine que je représente sortir de
cette vision comptable qu'on a de la
gestion
quand monsieur thibault dit qu'il a
trouvé nu e budget catastrophique ce
n'était pas le cas monsieur thibault en
arrivant a fait un audit par le
percepteur il il aurait dû faire l'audit
par par un indépendant dont la vision
comptable
l'exposition comptable du percepteur et
et d'intervenants extérieurs ne se
traduit pas par les mêmes termes donc il
faut sortir de cette vision comptable
je crois que nous nous sommes nous
sommes une commune au saint-esprit la
commune balnéaire
c'est la conclusion bruit pas commune
balnéaire nous avons un patrimoine à
faire valoir
nous avons des sources nous avons des
rivières nous avons des fourrés et je
pense que on peut trouver un
épanouissement dans la périphérie où
nous sommes et il faut faire valoir à
l'espace sud aussi que nous sommes une
commune rurale
merci beaucoup maryse plante et revu
alors à corps iso spiritaines nous
proposons une gestion tout au long de la
mandature
c'est à dire c'est pas on en a voyagé à
cela
le café chimay nour a fait toutes ses
vagues ali talât exemple en 2018 budget
fait c'était 58 mille euros 2010 9 85 me
donc la casamance je m'adresse au spirit
est piqueté fait le choix d'une équipe
d'hommes et de femmes réunis autour de
valeurs fortes de ces faits lité et de
transparence avec le souci permanent
d'être à votre écoute et porteurs de
projets réalistes réseau ni axée sur le
respect de la solidarité de la
communication et de la démocratie
nous vous proposons un changement majeur
une autre façon de vous servir dans un
esprit de famille dans un esprit de
cohésion en nous faisant confiance le 15
mars 2020 en faisant le choix d'une
équipe motivée rigoureuse cohérente et à
votre écoute ensemble redonner le
sourire à notre belle commune passe
pallier cet afflux ces patrimoines no
mercy maïs plantains maintenant à vous
monsieur miguel buval le père spiritain
l'espoir accordé en 2014 a été bafoué
peu de temps après les élections
la difficulté nous en aurons nous serons
les convertir en opportunités et ses
opportunités pour devons démontrer notre
savoir faire mais surtout outre à savoir
est ravie de vous alors et puis cet
esprit do good maïs d'esprit clèves est
en noir lépi miguel duval très bien bien
pour terminer cette émission c'est
d'avancer votre conclusion
olivier bérisson démission de mme une
fausse saint-esprit enfin c'est la liste
de noms la liste - cet esprit moon
matinik monte partout nous ni en
responsabilité s'est dit rétabli la
vérité du sanwi vie
et qui pèse son débat contesté de toutes
parts a fait un seul famille et fait
justice sévit vérité tu as là c'est à
dire
que lyon pouvait pilotes ayant tout fait
ballotte je ne pouvais pour l'autre et
l'injustice tard nos convives lits de
camp y vivent en harmonie
à quelle division ni d'un social ni de
l'ain économique
il gagne tout simplement dit moon qui
s'est véritable patrimoine cet esprit
parce que si you keep ou fait cet esprit
vif alors moon c'est faux saint-esprit
mais si un pile fausses et camper lamba
tout me voilà donc que les hérissons qui
a terminé donc cette série de
conclusions puisque c'est le tirage au
sort qui l'avait désigné d'ailleurs pour
justement être en dernier
parmi les cinq candidats donc en lice
pour l'élection comme une municipale et
communautaire à saint-esprit merci pour
votre attention votre fidélité émission
le rappelle encore réalisé par claudine
était le biel que j'ai donc eu le
plaisir de présenter avec alain livory
au chronométrage
il y avait michel joseph prochain débat
retrouver donc alors ce débat bien sûr
sera à retrouver en sur notre site
internet en podcast comme on dit il sera
mise en ligne sur notre site internet
dans quelques heures ou dc le lendemain
prochain débat en radio et sur internet
ce sera ce vendredi 21 donc avec les
candidats des trois îles et et puis ce
mardi 18 ans télévision franks hore et
christine cuppitt donc recevront les
candidats du vauclin voilà merci a
bientot spécial élections municipales
[Musique]